- [Voiceover] We've been working on
an intuitive description
of the natural response
of an LC circuit,
and in the last video,
we got everything set up,
and now, we're ready to close the switch.
Let's close our switch.
And now our switch is closed again,
and what happens?
Well, we had V naught.
We had some voltage on our capacitor,
and that means now we have some voltage
on our inductor.
That's what the switch closer did.
So all of the sudden,
our inductor finds itself
with some voltage across it,
so let's look at this equation here,
the inductor equation.
And it says that V naught,
that's the starting voltage
from the capacitor that we borrowed,
is L times the slope of the current.
Alright, so now we have a finite voltage,
and then we have a finite value on L,
and that means that DI, DT is some number,
and if we put positive charge up here,
we know that V naught is positive.
So let's sketch that.
Let's start a sketch of
what's going on here.
We're gonna plot together on the same plot
the current in blue,
and we'll put the voltage in orange,
and this is the time axis here.
So, let's go back and check.
What was our voltage when we started?
Our voltage was V naught
when the switch closed.
So I'll mark that out,
and what was the current when we started?
The current was zero,
so here's a zero current down here.
And now we're gonna sketch
in what we think happens
right after the switch closes.
So we decided that there was gonna be
some kind of a DI, DT.
DI, DT equals V naught over L.
I'm just gonna sketch this in.
There's gonna be some rising slope.
There's gonna be some
positive slope on the current.
Alright, so we took our first step.
Now, the other thing that's
happening here is that Q,
what is Q doing?
Let's track our charge.
Q is actually gonna start
flowing out of this guy.
This is the current that
we're talking about.
DI, DT, this is a finite current,
and that current is made of the charge
that's in the capacitor,
so that current starts flowing around
and running around to the bottom side
of the capacitor, right?
That means the amount of charge on the top
is going down,
which means that the
voltage is going down.
So let's sketch in some voltage.
The voltage is gonna start going down
because the charge is
leaving the capacitor.
Alright, so far, so good.
So let's keep going back and forth
between the inductor and capacitor,
and see how the voltage
and current changes,
and the way we do that is we just look
at the equation we had.
Now, the voltage on the
inductor is not V naught anymore.
It's changed to DI, DT
equals whatever V is over L,
and we notice that V
went down a little bit.
So that means what?
That means the slope of the current
went down a little bit.
So let me make a little shallower version
of the slope here.
Alright, now what happened
next to the voltage?
A little more charge
has left the capacitor,
headed over to the opposite plate,
so the voltage is gonna
continue to go down.
So now we're just gonna edge forward
moment to moment and see what happens.
Every time the voltage goes down,
the slope of the current
gets a little shallower, right?
And then the voltage continues to drop
because the current's leaving,
and eventually, that
voltage is gonna reach zero,
and at the point the voltage reached zero,
the slope of the current is zero.
The slope of the current is zero.
So right when this happens,
the slope of the current is zero.
Now, the value of the
current is some number.
Alright, so now we have
some value of current.
We have a zero voltage.
Now, when we have zero voltage,
let's go back up here.
When this value of voltage is zero here,
when this guy is zero,
that means that Q is zero,
and what that means is that
the charge on either side of the capacitor
is equalized.
The same charge exists on the top
and the bottom of the capacitor.
That's what this means here.
So in our next moment,
what's gonna happen next?
Does the voltage go flat?
Does it go flat sideways?
Does it go up?
Does it go down?
What does it do?
What does the current do?
Let's figure it out.
So I see we have a finite current.
Okay, what that means is
the charge is continuing to flow
in what direction?
In this direction here,
charge is continuing to flow like this,
and what's happening now
is we're getting excess plus charges
flowing on this side of the capacitor.
So we're actually building
up positive charge
on the bottom plate of the capacitor,
and what that means is,
the charge is reversed,
so the voltage is reversed,
and that tells us that we're gonna have
a negative voltage.
It's gonna start to grow here.
I have a negative voltage.
I go back to my inductor equation.
This value of V right here,
this is now negative,
so that means the DI, DT
has a negative slope,
and negative slope looks like
it's sloping down like this.
It starts to roll over and slope down,
and a little less current
means a little less slope on the voltage.
Now this positive current's gonna continue
to keep flowing.
It's gonna continue to deliver charge
to the bottom edge,
to the bottom plate of the capacitor.
At some point, that current will actually
go through zero again,
and if we look at this situation,
this is where we started from.
This is almost the
situation we started in.
There's zero current,
and there's a--
This time it's a negative voltage.
We started at a high voltage,
and we went to a negative voltage.
This voltage here happens to be
minus V naught,
and the reason is
is that all the charge
that was on the top now
has made a trip all the
way around to the bottom.
So the situation is perfectly reversed
from when we started.
Now, because of that symmetry,
we're not gonna make
this video any longer.
I'm just gonna say that this situation
will repeat itself.
Basically, the voltage will
curl back down like that,
and the current will do this.
Woops, let's just keep sketching in.
So we've repeated the same story
that we did at the beginning part
of the curve over here,
just with the voltage sign reversed.
And now we reach another state.
Now we have zero volts
and we have a negative current here,
and what we look at is we
duplicated this situation here,
just with the opposite
sign of the current.
There's positive current,
and here's zero voltage.
Now we have zero voltage
and a negative current,
so the whole story I told over here
is gonna be in reverse.
This charge now is
gonna reverse direction.
Let's take out all our arrows,
and all the charge we had
is gonna start flowing back
around this way like that.
This positive charge that we had
is gonna flow around
and meet up with the negative charge
that we accumulated up here,
and that's what's going on
in this part of the cycle,
and we can continue on.
Basically, this is gonna go
the same exact story like that,
and this, the current, will do the same,
and we began.
We've come back to the same exact point
as the starting point.
Now we've replicated our starting point.
So what's gonna happen next?
Well, what happens next is the same thing
that happened in the beginning,
and this curve actually repeats itself
as long as we let this circuit
sit here like this.
So I don't have to
continue with the story.
It's basically a repetition of everything
that happened here,
and what we're gonna
get is a rocking motion
on the voltage, back and forth,
and we're gonna get a rocking motion
on the current, back and forth,
as these energy storage elements
change stored charge for
energy in the magnetic field,
and back to stored charge,
and then it rocks back
and forth like that.
So this is our intuitive explanation
of what happens in an LC circuit
when we let it do its natural response.
There'll be this rocking motion
back and forth,
and now in the next video,
we're gonna go through
and see how this comes out mathematically.